ninety-year-old margaret keenan from
inniskillin
who lives in coventry became the first
person in the world
to receive a clinically authorized
vaccine
for covet 19. this marks
the start of the nhs's herculean task to
deploy vaccine right across the uk
in line with its founding mission to
support people according to
clinical need not ability to pay and
this
simple act of vaccination is a tribute
to scientific endeavor to human
ingenuity
and to the hard work of so many people
today marks the start of the fight back
against our common enemy coronavirus
and while today is a day to celebrate
there is much work to be done
we must all play our part in suppressing
the virus until the vaccine can make us
safe
and we can all play our part supporting
the nhs
to deliver the vaccine across the
country and this mr speaker is a task
with
huge logistical challenges like the need
to store the vaccine at ultra low
temperatures
the clinical need for each person to
receive two doses 21 days apart and i
know that the nhs will be equal to the
task
i'm sure we will do everything that we
can everything that's humanly possible
to make sure the nhs have whatever help
they need
the first eight hundred thousand doses
of the fisa beyond tech vaccine are
already here
in locations around the uk and the next
consignment is scheduled to arrive
next week this week we will vaccinate
from hospitals across the uk
from next week we'll expand deployment
to start vaccinations by gps
and we'll vaccinate in care homes by
christmas
and as more vaccines come on stream in
the new year
we'll open vaccination centers in larger
venues like sports
stadia and conference halls mr speaker
people do not need to apply
the nhs will get in touch at the
appropriate time
and when that times come we have one
clear request please step forward
for your country i want to thank all
those involved the international team of
scientists the globally respected
regulator the mhra
public health england the vaccines task
force and all the
volunteers who took part in the trial
and all
those who have come forward for
vaccinations so far
and all those who will do so in the
future months of trials
involving thousands of people have shown
that this vaccine works
and is safe and by coming forward you're
taking the best possible step
to protect yourself your loved ones and
protect the nhs
mr speaker help is on its way and the
end is in sight
not just of this terrible pandemic but
of the onerous restrictions that have
made this year
so hard for so many but even while we
can now see the root out
there's still a long march ahead let's
not blow it now
there are worrying signs of the virus
growing in some parts of the country
including parts of essex london and kent
and over the coming weeks and months we
must all keep
following the rules to keep people safe
and make sure we can get through this
safely together